and what I mentioned what the theorem
says it actually this protocol can be
made secure up to basically as close as
you want up to 50% corruption as long as
you set the parameters correctly this
protocol and what we meant by setting
the parameters correctly was that the
mining difficulty needs to be very
tightly calibrated to the network delay
in particular what we needed was at the
block time the time it takes the final
block need to be significantly bigger
than the network delay figured roughly
if you wanted to get close to 59 50% you
needed to be roughly 60 times Delta and
in fact somewhat magically this is
actually what you know how nakamoto set
it this 10 minute network delay in a 10
minute block time so let me give some
intuitions of how we kind of how we can
prove these type of statements okay so a
little bit more formally a property set
we have a clean mathematical especially
what it means for to set these
parameters correctly and this is what
the formal is I'm not going to prove
this actually I got formula well give
some intuition of why this kind of makes
sense so let alpha be the mining rate of
honest players so mining rate means is
how fast to own these players fine
blocks okay and beta is the mining rate
of the adversary if the attacker only
controls 50 then alpha equals better
their mining at the same rate refining
blocks at the same so ideally we like to
say this is secure when alpha is greater
and better good guys find things faster
and then bad guys but as I mentioned
there is an attack it needs to somehow
depend on on Delta so here the the
condition is that alpha time this times
this thing that depends on on Delta
should be greater and better so I need
so actually the good guys need to have a
bigger majority but how big it is
how much more I need decreases once the
mining rate goes down because this
mining rate alpha gets multiplied by
Delta so if I'm finding things much much
smaller than Delta then this alpha times
Delta becomes very close to to zero and
then I'm getting closer to just the
condition alpha equals alpha greatly
better so to give some intuition of why
things need to depend on Delta there is
actually a pretty good attack and this
is the attack from Dekker what offer so
what I realize is whatever good guy mind
something what you mine a block me as
the attacker I control the network if I
control a network I see this block first
you're just a single person you're alone
there's lots of other good guys out
there you you're not gonna just fight
that you found this block that is not
going to help you a lot because you're
just tiny but me as attacker I see this
first and I'm not going to give it to
everybody else I wait how long do i wait
well as long as I can so I take it I'm
delaying it for Delta steps and during
these Delta steps what do I do I'm gonna
be mining on this thing so now the
attacker actually gets some kind of
advantage every time a good block is
mined he gets Delta 3 times steps of
mining into today so very very high
level you would kind of think that if
the block time is like C times Delta so
blocks are done much or arrive much
slower than Delta then that one that you
get is just whatever C so it goes down
so that's very very high level ok
this is not a proof at all right ok so
let me at least give a high-level
overview of how we can prove sometimes
such a thing and the first thing we
should do is we have this complicated
protocol it's not so complicated but the
protocol around the moral is kind of
it's a litte bit messy the first thing
to do is to get rid of this random
Oracle and to consider a nicer kind of
process and the best way to actually do
this is to use runny kinetise Universal
composability framework and cannot try
to to find a nicer process that models
what's going on that simplifies things
okay so what we're going to do is to
define this idol functionality which we
call that F mine or f3 I think it's
called a paper that that removes this
messy protocol and instead just talks
about some kind of like mining
functionality okay so in this mighty
functionality we we have a tree okay
it's not real a chain but we have this
we have three blocks and the attacker
and the good guys at any given time
point they're going to say I would like
to extend a particular node here and
they can to try to mine from there and
with some probability P Rho TP I'm lucky
and I mine another block okay this kind
of like you know like I had this picture
I would I want to analyze the particular
tattoos that lets make sense with this
f3 is okay and this is a kind of messy
proof but it's like it's a no purely
cryptographic proof that's relatively
standard but random Oracle's to say the
way the protocol perhaps it's just
implementing this type of extension
functionalities you have the
functionality f3 I go to it attacker
goes to it
it point to something with probability P
it's successfully mining and in that
case it can extend it
okay so now we have this clean
abstraction and we know what the good
guys are doing they go every time they
point to long exchanges see an iterator
extended and the bad guy he cut any
given point point to any where he wants
and try to extend it okay it's still not
easy to analyze the protocol in this in
this type of model because I don't know
where the attack is pointing every time
so the key then and I think this is a
principle that applies only from the
earlier works and subsequent works is to
instead of analyzing this complicated
stochastic process that considers an
attacker does whatever he wants we're
not very good at analyzing kind of this
adversarial state stochastic processes
we'd like to reduce it to analyzing some
kind of just a basic stochastic process
we understand just look at the good guys
and let's identify some process
regarding the good guys and some good
property some good pattern that we would
like to occur okay and this is what we
do we define something called a
convergence opportunity that only looks
at what good guys are doing okay a
convergent portunity is going to be the
following good pattern the good guys are
unsuccessful in mining for Delta tile so
none of the good guys good yes we know
what they're doing every time they just
ask mine mine mine mine mine right for
Delta time steps no success then a
single guy Mohammed is lucky and he
succeeds yeah then Delta time steps
nobody's lucky ok this is a pattern this
is a pattern regarding good guys and
regarding this extension functional team
and we like to argue that this happens
often they'll discuss later on how to
analyze this and it's not it not be so
complicated this is now a very simple
Markov chain I'm like asking
I'm lucky with probability P people
asking asking and now what's the
probability or how often do I have
something where have silence for Delta
steps then a single guy succeeds its and
then silence for Delta steps how are you
counting the time here I'm counting a
discrete time at every every time step
all the good guys make a call to this F
mind functionality and some of them are
successful some are not so the time is
maintained by the time is by f milenberg
every time step I ask every time sits a
query to F magna as you can see all it
is converging portunity for this to to
happen
I need the difficulty to be set so that
we have like Silas with Delta step I
need to make sure that the block time is
longer than Delta and avoid this will
ever have never happen right so money
difficulty need to be done so that I
actually do get the silence without the
step so the blockchain is long yes but
it will always happen great point but I
wanted to happen often okay so it's good
it's gonna I wanted to happen
sufficiently often with high probability
I want to happen often yeah in fact what
I would like to say is that this
converts your pituitary
this happens happen often in any big
interval so any large field of time I
need to have many converts opportunities
how many what we like to make sure is
that this happens more often than a bad
guy finds new blocks so by said I want
to set the parameters so that I will get
more convergence opportunity more
dislike nice pattern than the the number
of successful queries that hacker has to
the MEF main functionality
so checking how many successful queries
he has to f mind that's very easy so now
I just argue that I have many good
conversion opportunities so no this
thing yes this converts opportunity
cutoff make sure the goodbyes are not
interfering with one another and also it
will prevent bad guys from interfering
with the good guys so let me like I will
in the next few slides kind of sketch
how these two pop please give you what
you want and then sketch how to get this
yeah okay so remember the way I
discussed this F mine is that I'm not
reduce the problem to having it all the
players at any time step we have
discrete time what they do is they go to
this idle functionality and they point
to some somewhere in this thing and I
say please mine and its functionality
says with probability P you're lucky and
then you're allowed to extend this
branch each note is successful with some
probability P but there are many of them
right so it could be that this
particular Turkestan both you and I
managed to mine and that would be
annoying because that we interfere with
one another yes so I want silence
silence silence silence 400 steps then
only you win you success and then
silence again nobody else does yeah the
attacker could do I don't care about the
tacky this is only come to good guys I
want to make sure that in fact I want to
make sure this converter opportunities
grow faster than a number of successful
mining static that the bad guy does
because I just mean that like this is
like I just mean silence like
convergence opportunity is is like this
silence Delta then we have this is yeah
success and then silence and just so the
life is a number of silence successes
you have this is a single commercial
opportunity then I need to like have
another one happening afterwards so I'm
very sexy like this would be now if I
had like this and I have two of them I
could have two hundred yeah and then I
said then I can keep the same one yes
yeah yeah like this thing now becomes
short if there's another successful
order and it's called
all right so let's first all get a very
simple thing this thing is actually
there's in the whole proof white
converts opportunities if I've every
time I have a commercial opportunity the
chain grows for all the good guys sorry
actually very easy to see what is that
what it's actually yeah
easy to see that whenever a commercial
printer happens we have this silence
that means that whenever that means that
when we get to this point all the good
guys have now seen whatever chain was
mine before so whenever this guy now
mind something it's going to increase
the chain by at least one from where it
was before it started after the second
silence yes so now he increases it but
then we have another silence and you
know it gets propagated to everybody
else at this point so chain grows now
the point is that the attacker maybe
could potentially mess things up for us
but it doesn't really only thing attack
you can do is to make sure that like he
can only way he can mess things up here
by sending something even longer right
because otherwise they're gonna ignore
it so in that case it grows also so
every time you have a commercial
opportunity you know that whatever the
chain was over here it actually will
have increased by one by one because
everybody if somebody had some chain of
a certain length everybody will have
that chain of that length when it come
to here they're a single guy wins he's
going to increase it in fact at this
point does really matter it's single
could be many but it's going to increase
for sure and then at this point
everybody has your case so chain grows
good commercial opportunity chain grows
now here's the more tricky argument and
I hope a lot can I mess it up the co
system on this is going to be a sketch
the actual proof is more subtle
Carib should convey the idea of why
converts opportunities are good so
assume we have a conversion portunity
for a certain length L now the point
here is that unless the attacker manages
so let's look at this is a converter
portunity for length L so what I mean by
for length L this means that here he
mined a chain of length L so a single
guy in mines a chain of length L at this
particular time okay what a claim is
that unless the attacker manages to also
mine a chain of this particular length
we know for sure that all good guys will
agree on what this block is if they
agree on this block to agree and
everything else because it's a chaining
because that's how the f3 I think that's
things right so if the attacker does not
manage to mind something here they have
all agreed on what this is so why is
that if the attacker does not manage to
mine a chain of length L okay I'm
simplifying things okay let's just say
that he never mind some people chain of
length L okay you're right that
eventually he could always like catch up
okay but we'll get to that shortly but
for now let's assume you never mind
something of length L if so all the good
guys will agree on what is a block is
and the reason for that is that at this
point was single guy who who owned it
right and since there is silence when we
get to this particular point everybody
has seen this thing and therefore the
chain now is going to be able length at
least L so good guys will never try to
mind something of late L make sense so
if we can just make sure that attacker
doesn't mind something of length L we're
good now this seems like a stupid thing
because of course the Takei can always
mind something like they'll just it's
going to take him some time right but
the point here now is that actually good
guys they're not going to let him like
mind something of length L very much
into the future because they are at that
point they're much further down so
they're going to ignore whatever he
sends us and that's from the past so
really in order for him to ruin this
opportunity he needs to mind something
of length L within that like you know
before after that point but before they
have reached this thing because
otherwise they gonna ignore it so it
doesn't have much time to do it so
really in order for him me to argue that
he does not manage to ruin this
convergence the only thing you need to
argue is that any sufficiently long
interval if he gets like just a little
bit extra time he still has less blocks
that he managed mind than a number of
converge opportunities
I know this is kind of vague and to the
give the actual proof is takes it longer
but the point here is that for any
sufficiently long period of time I'm
given that lack a slightly longer time
maybe a little here a little bit there
if the number of mining successful -
that he has is smaller than the number
converge opportunities I know that every
successful mining he has he can only
kill at most one so if you have less
than I have there will be at least one
where he does not manage to mine it
within the time for them to accept it so
really from this thing we conclude that
the only thing we need to do is to make
sure that the number of successful - he
has a smaller number of commercial
portunities so all that remains is kind
of to argue that this converter
portunities happen commonly right not
there there common and in fact I would
like to get some kind of concentration
binds on in any period of time there
should be sufficiently many of them and
now this really is actually just a very
simple this is actually a very simple
Markov chain right this is just say you
go and you have a probability of
succeeding and what's the probability of
getting silence single silence right
that's all you need to figure out so now
this is a simple Markov chain and you
should be able to just write down the
Markov chain and analyze it
unfortunately we do know of
concentration bands for Markov chain and
that's they're kind of slightly less
well understood and Markov chains or the
normal kind of concentration bands so
one could just write it down and try to
analyze it yeah we tried that first
that's not very familiar with this
concentration was a Markov chain
so after trying a little bit gave up on
that and instead try to give a more
complete oracle proof and what can I
shall do that
it's instead of like you know if you
smart enough you have to try to be
clever instead and that's kind of what
what can do answer is actually a very
simple approach for for bounding
forgetting a concentration abundant
number of converge opportunities and
that approach is is this I can just tell
it in a few steps so first you can use
just normal Journal point to say how
many successful - we have right how many
times the good guys succeed
that's just normal Journal plan because
we know where every time independent
with probability P so that's very easy
now the question is like when we have
these periods of silence to look at that
we can look at another random variable
which is distances between successful
minds and I know that if this difficulty
is set appropriately small the distance
between successful minds should be big
she'll be greater than Delta right so
average the distance should be greater
than Delta and if the average is greater
than Delta I can use no concentration
bands again to say that the number of
distances that are smaller than Delta or
small okay so I'll call that kind of
like a bad event Minh between successful
minds the silence period is short so
every such bad event can kill two
successful minds right because if this
silence is short here then it can kill
off this guy and kill on this guy so
every time this distance is between to
success mining is small I kill of two
things
and that's the whole proof okay and
that's why when you look back to his
formula there was a factor two there
somewhere coincidentally this factor two
should not be there okay this is the
whole reason why we have this gap
between attack and analysis if I can
remove that factor to the analysis
actually would be tight now actually
subsequently as I mentioned a B and some
quarters to some Markov chain guys from
Northeastern decided to actually
the right thing to do is come on just
analyze the Markov chain which they did
I think both elliptic linux and
experimentally and indeed managed to get
something tighter but I don't think they
have a clean a simple expression so at
least you know this doing this kind of
we're stupid thing a geek at least gives
you a simple expression that is off by a
factor - maybe yeah likes India but if
you you know instead of doing that
simple thing you can write analyze their
actual market change all right so let's
go get back to where the high-level
picture the point here is we know that
Nakamoto now if you set the nine
difficulty correctly right so that the
block time is long then the protocol is
secure and Achebe consistency chain
quality and integrity and results of
this attack that we saw and in fact that
tack says that if the my elliptical is
not set correctly then the protocol is
completely broken so in particular what
it says it for every fixed instantiation
of the protocol with some particular
money difficulty if the network delay is
longer I can completely break it
all right so in more abstract terms what
we have concluded here is that in the
random Oracle model under the assumption
that attacker controls let's say point
49 or computational resources where you
can go at any as close as you want to
point five we can get a protocol that
satisfies synchronous state machine
replication because the protocol
parameters needs to be set as a function
of Delta so this is actually kind of a
subtle point because people often think
you look at much like a motor say look
this protocol is not parametrized by
network delay right there is nothing
there talks about network delay it
doesn't have this classic structure that
we our standard protocols to where you
say wait for Delta time right it doesn't
do that but actually because of the
mining difficulty it needs to be set
correctly so it actually is a
synchronous protocol also make sense
this point
now we also said this protocol is not
secured in partially synchronous setting
right we said that for any Association
of many difficulty the rates of networks
layered breaks it but maybe there's
something else that exists but maybe I
could have a better protocol that's
partially synchronous in this
permissionless setting the mining rate
of good guys yeah what's the probability
you know people join or leave and
changes and functions so how do you
understand the dynamics through this
analysis is it fair point if at any
moment in time that equation holds that
are fine or are there like some yeah you
need that equation to hold so the
analysis assumes it's hold all
throughout you can probe if this if
there's nothing hold for a short period
of time usually cannot do too much
damage but like I don't think it's
enough to say it hold on average but
the analysis assumes it does everywhere
right but yeah as long as this equation
holds everywhere yes yeah so as long as
the things are always set so okay so
what I explained here didn't occur say
difficult adjustments there are papers
doing it with difficult estimates also
it becomes more messy so you can do it
with difficult judgment also as long as
at any given point the condition holds
you need certain other things also you
need actually let me not go into it it's
a little bit more messy all right yes
that is definitely yes yeah yeah if the
amount of money changes to the delay is
broken okay so leave the question so
this is in a sink resetting leaves the
question what you can do in a partially
synchronous setting can you actually get
something turns out it's not just that
you have an attack on this particular
protocol it's impossible to get any type
of partial synchronous protocol as long
as we are we don't know exactly how many
players are there even if you have proof
of work so even it's proof work setting
if your uncertainty about how many
players are showing up in particular a
two factor approximation only so if you
don't know if it's going to be 50 or 100
people showing up then you cannot get
sometimes partially synchronous
how many people are there but as I said
in the normal right if the protocol gets
as input only an approximation of how
many people are there that is that
within a factor - then you cannot get
something that is that works in the
partial sync resetting when you see
majority you'll see facto half this is
not honesty right this is not what the
number of honest player this is say even
if the attacker only has like a tiny
tiny fraction of computational resources
right attack is very very weak if
players are not aware of how many other
players router yeah well a factor to you
cause exactly this is trivial this is a
trivial impose exactly so this is
actually a trivial lower bound but it's
not that this changes things from the in
the permission setting you clearly can
get things are partially synchronous
need to know exact yes exactly
right so as I said like let's go back to
our starting slide about what does
permissionless mean and now we've
learned things you don't mind you just
mean that they're you take majority with
their change
being there means that the running
protocol which I think as long as they
broadcast a chain and you take them when
till you take the majority no I don't
know what that means to me I'm like now
I'm just saying if any kind of protocol
that is not aware of the exact number of
players he'll not be partially
synchronous even with proof-of-work if
you're not following protocol honestly
you're not there that's it maybe getting
cpu power you can say the cpu you can
also do this without proof work this is
something that makes it I find if I
could discuss it more I'll get back to
this point much more detail like the
point I'd like to make here is that
right now here the conclusions of what
we know about the permissionless model
okay so in the permission setting we
knew exactly how many people are there
and who they are in the permission as we
said we don't wanna know how many people
are actually showing up and the point
here is that that forces us to work a
synchronous model in a portion of
synchronous model we cannot do it if we
don't have full awareness a manager okay
number two this other very simple
observation is that if you want to deal
with people that join late you cannot
get ad minus one this is something that
was discussed already earlier you need
to have an honest majority okay dollar
strong doesn't work if on a deal with
people that show up late again a very
very simple impossibility by just doing
this kind of you shop this guy's to say
one thing this case say one thing I
don't know who to trust so you need to
deal with layer knee you need to assume
honest majority
sighs so joining is the same his clients
famous times yeah because the client
wasn't there he joins late and he's like
we should address and then finally
without authentication mechanism you
need proof work so the conclusion here
is actually Nakamoto it's pretty great
the fact that it was synchronous seemed
like a deficiency but no it's needed
like a moti need under these assumptions
you satisfies it and these assumptions
are needed so if you want fully
permissionless fully for the permission
is consensus you need to have a
synchronous model communication energy
parameters needs your protocol needs we
parameterize by delta you can only get
honest majority and you need proof work
so with like proof of stake and so on
the would look different or I mean a lot
right it would not satisfy permission
less because their impossibility results
okay so what a need proof work is that
you were not here when I present an
impossibility results from our paper run
and you know the first one was right but
there is an impossibility result the
first one was in without authentication
you can always split people into the two
things and you can never hope to get
consistency you need to make sure that
this type of like simulation is costly
that with it right train model doesn't
work yes you need no the point is yeah
without authentication mechanism you
need to have something where simulation
is costly okay sorry it cost the
simulation yes
I'm not you know you need something
where the simulation is costly okay let
me just mention this like the profess
texting profess texting I will discuss
it monitor a little bit later on but
there you actually give up on this thing
you give up on this anyone can join
property and you say that you have only
the people that have some kind of public
keys are allowed to join this is not
it's not open its not permissionless
anymore it's only the people have staked
are allowed to join work is in some
sense just like I mean you also need to
spend resources you also need to have is
about anybody okay so the just translate
like proof of stake is just a much more
direct way to know I claim that it's
actually very different okay so let's
let's look at any type of this type of
proof estate mechanism where it's only
the people that you have some kind of
picky I it's only the stakeholders that
can participate if all those
stakeholders collude right for whatever
reason they collude and they say you
know what today we're gonna decide that
interest the transaction fees are going
up to $1.00 per transaction okay there
is nobody can prevent them from doing
that the fact that you have sometimes
truly permissionless a second means that
anybody can join means that actually
whenever this happens other people can
start to join in the system and jacob
has this very nice paper showing that in
that case there is nobody can hold the
system hostage because other people will
enter the system and bring down the fees
so it really it's very very important
that you have this totally free entry
now this obviously comes with a cost to
do this type of proof work but if you
want to have this totally free entry you
need to have a mechanisms that ensure
that you cannot do this that simulation
is costly but the see
I mean for example can it still be done
if you know you you're adding these
parties but the steak is only in the
ends of the two honest parties can you
still do the simulation in prove any
type of proof steak is some setting we
assume that there exists some kind of
authentication mechanism yes you may
pick your infrastructure
but that means that only those people
have the public keys they can
participate the system is closed to
those guys and means that those guys can
hold the system hostage if they want to
right now maybe it's hard to get
everybody well steak - to collude but
you know in this world isn't that like
1% controls 99 percent the resources or
whatever the numbers are so in that case
1% of the richest people could consume
could hold 99 percent hostage if you
wanted to they'd oh yeah but so so it
really if you want to be fully
parishioners you need to prevent this
kind of course the simulation and you
need scarcity you can find for example
take all the CPUs in the whole world
that's your total CPU ya know so you can
say use scarcity using CPU scarcely
using the PKI that sets up scarcity you
need some scarce resource short but the
key is authentication right so
generating scarcity by saying there's n
people no you have to prevent the cost
assimilation I agree I'm just saying if
you don't want any type of variation
some resource it could be CPU yeah it's
an abstract resource if you want scarce
doesn't like it doesn't have to be
resource you can say you do simulation
Prison regeneration is costly pulley if
you assume that I have some magical
government's power the simulation is
possibly and it has nothing to do with a
certainty well I mean basically if you
have infinite amount of this resource no
then you that's hard to argue about the
power of the adversary you need to
somehow say the answer is limited
controls anywhere have this discussion
and I will we can get back to I'll maybe
I'd like to try to run through the rest
first and get back to this philosophical
discussion because I think this is the
most interesting of what permissionless
actually means right so maybe have a few
minutes first and to discuss this this
thing but the conclusion here is you
know like a motto on this assumption
achieves it and so that's very good
there's a lot of deficiencies with this
protocol and I hope that in later
workshops there are improved methods for
dealing with many of these deficiencies
as we said it's slow you can maybe
improve this 60 Delta to be better we
don't know right only thing we know is
needs to be a function of Delta so the
impossibilities us the throughput is low
there's a bunch of very nice works
trying to improve the throughput it's
not completely free they achieve
slightly weaker security if you only
improved throughput so it still have a
nice open first question one thing we
discussed was this fairness issue to
incentive compatibility the chain
quality here isn't good and I will maybe
very briefly discuss why that is the
case and how it can be overcome and the
final thing is it does use this wasteful
proof works and the question is like can
we kind of circumvent it and as argue
before if you want to be in the fully
permissionless plain model this seems to
be the way to go but maybe you can relax
something right to get rid of it so I'll
discuss these two things very shortly so
the first one is we had this
well the number of transaction
transaction is different than block you
talk about you know let me not go this
is experimental numbers right this is in
practice it has fewer fuse of
transactions than hands per second let
me go into it it there will be in future
programs many people who discussed this
thing this is maybe the main bottleneck
in terms of scaling like how to scale a
Bitcoin and I won't have time to discuss
that there's lots and lots of nice very
nice works in that
so here to just this protocol is worse
of course than classic protocols because
it requires spending so much
computational effort but and why do
people do it
why would any sane person start mining
well there is a very good reason the
reason they do it is because they make
money by doing it and this was a genius
in nakamoto's protocol he said start
doing all this mining why because
whenever you mind a block that's what
it's called mining it's gold
you actually get a Bitcoin right right
because you get a few of them then you
have a house right so there's also
transactions fees but for now let's
ignore the transaction fees and so the
problem with this with the fact that
whenever you mine a block you get
rewards is that you actually really need
to have a blockchain now that has good
chain quality because otherwise an
attacker can spend as much resources in
you and get potentially twice as much
money then nobody is going to be idiots
and do the only thing they will just run
attack instead so it's not in certain
compatible so once you start paying for
people to do something you need to make
sure that it's actually worth much for
them to do it
okay there is a moderation about their
variants of these rewards and the money
pulls the zone I won't have time to
discuss that we'll just focus on this
fairness issue so ideally what would we
want ideally what we want is that if I
look at this chain things are popping up
if I control a fraction X of the
resources then actually get an
extraction of the blocks right
that's what I want I control 30% to
recomputation Reese's in the world
actually got 30% of the rewards so we
cannot hope to do that but we can maybe
get you know something close to it by
the turn of pan right that maybe control
access you get one minus epsilon times X
if I have that that would be great at
least if I only consider rewards there
is also some way of dealing with fees
forget about it here I don't have time
but one we can argue now is it actually
if I have something that is fair in the
sense that if I control a pea fraction
of the ERISA F X fraction resources
I get extraction rewards when it's
incentive compatible and attack you can
never get modern desserts I want to run
the protocol great now does Nakamoto
achieve it turns out no it's horrible
okay it's really really horrible a
particular attack and it controls one
half can get all the blocks and if you
control one third you can get half the
rewards okay so this seems bad right
let's actually go over this example it's
really cute and beautiful and it's
actually intriguing this and so this is
called a selfish mining this was
popularized by this beautiful paper by
Yellen and cereal but actually when you
go back it's in the Bitcoin forum in
2010 they already had this attacked with
very nice it wasn't a forum analysis but
they had a nice little Excel spreadsheet
showing how well the attack succeeds
with a bunch of different parameters and
the attack is really easy so you see
what you should do yeah let's say a
bunch of we have exchanges growing bla
bla bla bla bla
the attacker tries to mind something
whenever he minds a block he's like I
control the network why should I ever
give it to anybody else
I just withhold it okay and I let the
good guys do whatever they do okay so I
would hold it I let the good guys
continue working in the meantime I try
to me
extended my thing also but even
forgetting about that I just would hold
it then I wait until a good guy comes
along and he mind the block Walter why
do we learn right any minds a block what
I do is I'm gonna delay his block and
then I sent my block to everybody else
well so this is in fact why on the bit
confirmed 2010 they had all this example
had these numbers and so on and said
this is really terrible and then he said
well but in practice is not so easy
delay things so it's maybe not so
relevant yes you get a conflict and in
fact that's that's very nice to the
paper by Yellin Syrian they'd analyze
what happens when you put it up if you
have a sort of successful built a
winning and you can yeah so it's still
exactly and meanwhile you can continue
this thing and so you can gain something
there too so even then you can gain
things right but even the simplest thing
of like just withholding control Network
you only gain something and let's see
how much again by doing this thing okay
let's assume attacker controls one-third
so over a period of time over T steps
the good guys will have on average
gotten two thirds T looks the bad guy
will have gotten 1/3 T blocks but every
time he gets something he could kill off
in this example one block for the good
guy
he really killed off well because
nobody's gonna ever look at this thing
yes because I delay and his block I
delay it and I give this thing to
everybody this is you know this is not
fair adverse early model or attacker
controls network okay I'm you know we
are in that material model in that verse
early model this is why we get the bound
you know the bound right in the positive
result that's what we consider this very
negative model Snurfer negative so so
that's how many blocks the the good guys
caught and the number of blocks in a
chain is 230 so during his spare time so
therefore the the sorry the the attacker
got
yes attacker the good guys get 1/2 the
attacker gets 1/2 so by controlling 1/3
of the resources I get half of the
blocks very bad ok
indeed this requires you to control the
network which maybe is you know that's
the response to what are calling
practitioners but the Bitcoin people
that own Bitcoin and so on why they're
not very worried about this thing
because maybe it's very hard to actually
perform this attack you practice your
previous proof kills doesn't fail the
proof doesn't fail in fact the proof
gave the exact that number if you
remember that's the proof it's the proof
right so that's why they put in the
previous thing we had this bizarre
expression then let's give exactly this
number yeah and I think Vasilis will
actually I'm not gonna spend much time
with this thing because there's a whole
industry in there trying to understand
this turbo tax and I think the series
we'll talk much more about this app
which money attacks so this is just to
point out why chain quality kind of it's
important to look at this chain called a
separate property because it's needed in
order to properly incentivize people and
there's a reason why the bad the bound
was bad because there is action our
target is in a service area model okay
there is a way that we can get around it
in fact don't have time wheel to go over
it maybe
Versalles we'll talk about later on so
we have this protocol that gives you the
curve of this approximate furnace and it
gives you absolutely something
compatibility along
so the theorem is you can actually get
something that's absolutely simply
compatible where absolute is one of your
poly this is still not satisfactory you
would like to get an epsilon or they're
absolutely negligible we don't know how
to do that that's still an open problem
I know several people working on it but
as far as I know nobody has still
managed to get something that actually
advantage by deviating is negligible
because one our poly might still not be
great good enough to practice because if
they're even if it's one over poly why
not do it right yes no yeah then yeah
but still you would like it would be
great at least from a theoretical point
of view to have something as a Nash
equilibrium right it's true that
everybody's are doing this then it's not
worth doing it that's a problem right
but yeah we know it's not a Nash
equilibria to following protocol at
least right supposed to do selfish money
yeah it doesn't work ya know you don't
then nobody does anything that's a
problem but everybody like whatever you
bought oh yeah then everybody's quiet
it's very well it's very consistent it's
just not much liveness
the reason why we're discussing the
approximate and center permittivity is
because no no no this is an open problem
exactly I even the exact we don't know
yeah that would be even better yes this
is I'm just saying even to get neglige
but would be great No yeah we've thought
about it for a long time which is like
very hard to analyze like
yeah but now we're in the permission
yeah and yeah it's even then I think
it's fair it's like tricky right sturdy
like this basic totally it's the same
even if you control it up minority
there's a small probability then you get
lucky you have more power than the
honest people saying it's optimal we
don't know okay very good up a problem
to get something since fully incentive
compatible either fully or Epsom being
negligible right now the only thing we
know is whenever poly which is only
better than like a motor which was
basically not so let me get to this last
point that we want to discuss here of
like do we need to waste energy in this
guy is tired just like I am now
so he doesn't like to waste energy so
let's go back to this thing and we said
if we have the permission thing we need
all these three things
maybe we can relax well we said that
without authentication we need to have
some kind of costly costly resources
being expended in the protocol so maybe
let's just like give up on this thing
and say that let's start off with a
model we have authentication okay so
this is actually this is kind of like a
proof of stake setting we have some
initial setup we have some
authentication mechanism or in fact I
will assume a PKI we can then say okay
we gave up on this thing no action
suggestion but these are the two
properties are still useful
Koufos tech requires a preset pikiao
that's what you have the way I
understand proof a stake in any protocol
that's out there you start out by having
some initial stake their peak public is
initially in the system if you don't
have anything impossibility holds no if
you don't if you start up with nothing
then you have impossibility I mean the
stake is associated to the public key
right yes let's take our public keys
so if you start off with nothing no the
protocol needs some common knowledge of
what the initial public keys are that's
how it is in all protocols and if your
protocol doesn't have it then apply
there possibility results from the 2005
paper which your quarter okay all right
so right now I'm gonna let go of this
thing and assume that we have a PGI as I
said in a previous text setting for
instance we do have Licari because you
typically assume that we have some pre
mind coins they're called but they're
really just a public key infrastructure
the coins are different keys and now we
can ask yourself if we assume a public
key can we deal with the fact that
people are coming and going this
uncertainty number of players and
adjoining late joining is easy
that's all stop but dealing with the
fact that we don't know how many people
are around is still an issue okay and if
we go back to all the protocols that
Allen's showed in a classic setting
they're really very strongly relied on
the fact that I do some something it's
not right if I get 2000 signatures I
need to know what n is right otherwise I
cannot check if I get 2,000 signatures
so all these color classic protocols
very very strongly rely on the fact that
you know exactly how many people around
it's not clear it's necessary right
maybe you can do better so that's what
we called it a sleepy model which is
like the weaker version of
permissionless setting where I gave you
authentication I give you
P i okay but I still would like to get
their bust nurse in a setting where I
don't know how many people are showing
up okay so I'm gonna assume make
assumptions about the fraction of people
among the people that show up I'm going
to assume that fifty percent are honest
yeah
and indeed it turns out that's needed
right by this type of argument you need
to make sure among the people showing up
50 percent need to be honest
so that's necessary and sufficient and
it turns out that action approaches is
very easy it's not as easy to analyze
but it follows similar ideas to the
annals of Nakamoto and the idea is
actually can we kind of take like a
motor and remove proof of work from it
okay and make use of the fact that we
have a PGI and that allows us to remove
true for work okay so
the key insight here which I think was
made in this mythical energy paper by
Alan Shearer and Robert Varanasi is it
what does proof-of-work do in this
setting proof work really just is a
leader election mechanism so we're
electing some guy and then he gets to
package transaction to the next block so
maybe we can kind of since we have this
PGI we can maybe use some other
mechanism for electing a leader and the
key idea would be so maybe let's try to
do the same type of mining happens in
Bitcoin but say that every individual he
only gets one guess per second okay so
if I make sure that's it I can only give
you one guess per second that's a way to
kind of do this kind of mining that's
not wasteful this is kind of vague but
we'll maybe see later on very shortly
how to do it okay so recalling like a
motors protocol at every instance we try
to do this hashing to see if I'm gonna
be elected leader and then I get to the
package block now I'm going to replace
it by the following puzzle checking
mechanism your solution to the puzzle is
going to be your name at a time step
okay that's the only thing you're
allowed to check and if you put in
something that's not your name my time
step that's an invalid solution for this
particular time step okay so at any
given point what you do is you're gonna
be mining but every second you just do a
single invocation to hash function and
what do you put in your pain saviors
name if you're Sylvia and the current
time and you check if it's smaller than
thee
and if you're elected leader then you're
gonna take whatever we did put into
Nakamoto before the previous like the
end of the chain current chain the new
transactions and the puzzle solution and
you sign it using your secret key and
this is what kind of make sure that you
you're using the speaker now to say that
you are actually the right person who
won in this round alright so there it is
very very simple I'm just making sure
that you're not allowed to try any kind
of puzzle solution because then you
would be allowed to mine I was saying at
second seventeen you can only try one
solution which is your name for 17
that's the protocol make sense like one
important thing to point out here is
that note we're doing something
different here we're putting in just the
positive solution here we're not putting
in before we put in transactions and the
thing here why don't we do that then you
can actually try a bunch of different
transactions to see if you get elected
leader more often so that's why it's
important here in order to check what
your leader I'm just putting your name
and the time and that decides whether
you the leader then later on we're using
this i'm authenticating the block that
you're doing using your signature if
you're the leader okay very good point
here is like this I need to make a
little bit extra restriction it's not
quite work it doesn't quite work the
important thing now is like I'm not
actually going to allow you to put in
any time step but in the blockchain I'm
going to require this time steps to be
strictly increasing so otherwise the
point yeah
- of course is that if I'm elected
leader time 17 maybe I'm gonna use that
thing at time 18 also right or maybe I'm
going to be elected leader two years in
the future maybe use it now we don't
allow it
we're requiring these time cells to be
strictly increasing
number one and second of all is whenever
you send me something where time stamp
into the future if it's this is too far
into the future saying no way right this
is for tomorrow not now okay
that was very this protocol does not
give it up to security right because
everybody can figure out exactly when
you're going to be the next leader that
is a completely public so if I can
figure out that you're going to be the
leader tomorrow so I might want to
corrupt you and indeed so this original
thing just keeps you gives you one-half
corruption in this model where I don't
know how many people around actually so
this is the key thing right I don't know
how many people are showing up all right
there might be a hundred people showing
up or a million people showing up as
long as a majority of the people showing
up are honest
it works but it's only static corruption
you can get it to work with it up the
corruption using kind of Vivi reversed
and tricks also right now you cannot
generate more identities because only
the people that have a registered public
key can do this right we start off
assuming that we have a public
infrastructure and we assume that we
have common knowledge on what the set of
public keys are right we start off with
common knowledge about the public you
can if you want to more efficiently if
you don't do it the protocol just gonna
be a bit slower okay before 810 people
show up we're going to confirm
transactions at the one tenth of the
speed but it's gonna work right so
you're like this here like this
decreases one code we haven't done it
but you could probably do some kind of a
difficult adjustment also but it's like
already messy the way it is but so but
probably one could do it old yeah
choose the caches just take the smallest
one of the only other players is the one
so it's not so easy to get agreement on
that right that's a great method if we
have a broadcast channel but we don't
have broadcast channel so that's the
yeah so this is kind of a like yeah okay
so we're kind of running out of time so
I guess what I really want you to
remember is like what it means for
something to be permissionless consensus
okay and the features again to recall is
that we're in a setting where notes are
not aware how many people are showing up
okay people can join late and we have
this free entry condition that anybody
can join right that's what I would call
the pure permissionless setting anybody
should be allowed to join yep
I don't make money ever I never bought
any of it cause I lost my bike you know
nowhere in there in this so this is a
protocol but there is you don't need to
have any mining rewards if you don't
want to because it's so cheap to run it
right but if you want you could give
people mining words so this is like so
this is now I'm working in a setting
where I have a fix like there is a
public key setting right so it's all of
us are public keys but maybe some of us
is participating others are not maybe I
would like in order to incentivize
people to participate maybe I'll give
them something to mind also but you know
you don't have to maybe people these are
not these things that's a transaction
that's was like what I'm put when I'm
signing here is the old end of the chain
then set a new set of transaction that's
a block and deposit solution which was
just in the number right so positive
solution is just time step in my name so
this really like consensus doesn't you
don't need to have these incentives here
at all it really is just trying to
achieve consensus in a setting where I
don't know how many people are actually
showing up I'm just relaxing that thing
that we have uncertainty maybe 10% show
up 100 percent show up I don't know
where how many and I want to concerns in
that setting but I have a public key
infrastructure then this public
infrastructure if you're a proof of
stake setting you get it automatically
as I said because that's the coins and I
think we'll hear about that later on
another I think tomorrow probably we
talk about yeah run
because an IP address I can just pretend
that's the point I can say that my IP
address is 57 and you can check it the
key I can sign that's the whole point it
enables doing it right if I can relax it
impossibility from your paper incentives
so I wanted to keep away incentives here
because we'll talk about later
all right so conclude the fact that we
don't know how many notes roll that
imposes the restriction that we need to
deal with synchrony we need to have a
synchro solution and the fact that we
won't deal with late joining means we
need honest majority and now the
controversial thing maybe if we don't
have any authentication mechanism what
I'm arguing is we need to have a
protocol that's computationally
intensive because otherwise we have this
impossibility so in this previous
solution so in order to deal with
adaptive corruption we're using tricks
similar to the vrf this is kind of like
a stronger crypto it's kind of a mess
here
you need to buy enigk sub-exponential
hardness and analysis we can prove under
subjects Manchus security of Music's
and that you can implement some kind of
f9 functionality so that's kind of a you
see proof again as before and once you
have that you can analyze everything
abstractly again so you kind of if the
crypto as you do and then you do the
probability analysis later on any clean
model is common reference string so this
is kind of like it's not just enough to
have a public infrastructure you need to
make sure that
we need to have basically there are
various issues with this verifies that
make sure that you need to have some
extra randomness that's selected
honestly so yeah so the conclusion here
is that if you want something in this
setting nakamoto does it which is great
okay and indeed it uses all these
different assumptions and they're needed
and if you don't want proof work you can
remove it and you can still at least get
the following the first two properties
so it's kind of a little bit
permissionless if you're a public
infrastructure at least and potentially
if you're happy with a proof of tax
scheme then maybe you can assume a
public infrastructure but as I would
argue that doesn't really doesn't give
you full free entry because only the
people have stake in the system they can
enter and that has certain economic
consequences that they can kind of hold
the system hostage
to say that because it's not okay it's
not completely free today to buy this
thing I agree
but in principle you could have a scheme
where yeah you have something where you
cannot use this Asics and then anybody
was a computer can enter so at least it
has the potential getting that yes I
didn't say that like a moto satisfies
for today but at least anything that you
know where we restrict to a group of
people in the permission study for sure
does not have the free entry it's at
least like a motor thing maybe it goes
towards it right yeah
potentially right yes if you if you view
this as freedom the fact that you need
to just invest a million dollars to buy
equipment you cannot right I cannot
personally but maybe you can so we don't
know we're not fully free yet so so the
point here the conclusion is there are
trade-offs right this thing burns the
earth but it gives us more freedom and
maybe that's also do you have to decide
where you want to be on freedom versus
nature yeah
yes
[Applause]
[Music]